merci à Daniel Riolo d'être là toujours
en plusieurs de t'avoir mont Daniel
journaliste éditorialiste et qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé en fait alors ce weekend
il y avait donc week-end de la lutte
contre l'homophobie les joueurs devaient
porter un maillot arc-en-ciel on a vu
moi j'ai vu les joueurs du PSG qui
l'avaient tous et certains joueurs ont
refusé de le porter c'est ça
comme tous les ans on a chaque fois que
cette journée contre l'homophobie dans
le foot a lieu à chaque fois on a les
mêmes problèmes j'ai presque
l'impression que ça s'intensifie je
crois que l'année dernière ça avait des
données des débats animés ici
Mathieu et Gilles en fait
qui avait pas du tout assumé il avait
inventé un mal de tête ou je ne sais
quoi pour pour pas jouer maintenant les
joueurs le revendiquent carrément ça a
été le cas des quatre ou cinq
Toulousains qui ont pas voulu jouer plus
d'une antenne donc il y en a de plus en
plus alors si on veut voir le bon côté
des choses on peut quand même dire que
globalement la très très grande majorité
des joueurs ont porté le maillot même si
c'est à contrecœur même si c'est
en disant qu'ils n'ont pas envie de le
faire l'important c'est qu'il finisse
par le faire en fait ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est qu'il n'arrive pas à
se mettre dans la tête que ils ne font
pas ça pour soutenir une cause qu'on
leur demande pas de se déguiser en drag
queen qu'on leur demande pas de se
mettre sur un char avec une plume dans
le derrière pendant la Gay Pride mais
qu'on leur demande juste
de porter un maillot qui est contre
l'homophobie en gros
contre les agressions ou les choses qui
peuvent aller à l'encontre d'un
homosexuel voilà c'est juste ça c'est
lutter contre l'homophobie mais
visiblement ils ont du mal à comprendre
ça en fait je crois pas qu'ils ont du
mal je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
d'hypocrisie ils font comme s'ils ne
comprennent pas je pense qu'ils
comprennent très bien et que tout
simplement pour des convictions
personnelles qui sont souvent des
convictions religieuses ils ne veulent
pas participer à ce mouvement c'est
clair net je préfère la version de ce
qui assume à ceux qui se cachent comme
gars il y avait pu le faire l'année
dernière alors Gilles cette année donc
ça a commencé c'est les joueurs de
joueurs de Toulouse non
[Musique]
certains joueurs et donc mais est-ce
qu'ils ont droit de pas le porter s'ils
veulent pas alors visiblement certains
auront à Nantes une sanction financière
possiblement mais il y aura pas de
sanctions sportives à part le fait
d'avoir été écarté là et le Conseil
national de l'éthique les a tens
verbalement mais ne devrait pas les
sanctionner moi il y a la ministre des
Sports qui intervenu oui la ministre des
Sports oui elle est pour elle plus de
fermeté alors encore la fermeté c'est
elle peut pas elle peut demander une
sanction tu peux la sanction c'est
l'abandon de poste parce qu'en gros tu
devais jouer un match tu l'as pas joué
le Nantais le club
il cherche à éviter la relégation
c'était un match hyper important il
aurait pu aider son équipe pour des
convictions personnelles
ne pas jouer plutôt que de porter ce
maillot qui visiblement était un digne
pour lui il y a 5 joueurs de Toulouse il
y a un joueur de Nantes et un joueur de
guingampoules moi en fait je ne
cautionne pas l'attitude de ces joueurs
on est bien d'accord mais je tente de
les comprendre
laissez-moi juste tenter d'expliquer
parce que disent les Américains sur le
mais tout ce qui précède le met c'est
pourri alors je ne cautionne pas c'est
plutôt je ne cautionne pas du tout leur
attitude mais je vais tenter de vous
l'expliquer notamment pour les joueurs
qui sont sénégalais
égyptiens par exemple au et en Égypte on
est bien d'accord et c'est dramatique
être homosexuel c'est risquer d'être
poursuivi d'être battu potentiellement
d'être emprisonné donc ça c'est une
honte absolue maintenant ce que je
voudrais juste dire c'est que les
familles de ces joueurs qui vivent au
pays dans ces cas-là ils viennent pas
jouer en France alors je finis juste ma
phrase parce que je sais ce que tu vas
dire de ces joueurs sont menacés et en
France
ces joueurs ont peur puisqu'ils ont peur
ils se mettent en danger ils viennent
pas jouer en France voilà pourquoi voilà
pourquoi il ne porte pas le maillot ils
ne sont pas ils ne sont pas homophobes
ils ont peur de leur famille et des
antidépresseurs
vont vont être en danger donc si
ils portent un maillot qui n'est pas un
maillot représentatif des LGBT encore
une fois c'est important de préciser
c'est un maillot qui est là uniquement
pour dénoncer les violences faites à une
minorité dans notre pays dans un pays
qui je te le rappelle est un pays laïque
ou la religion n'a rien à faire il
présente quelque part notre pays même
s'ils ne sont pas français en jouant
pour une équipe de France c'est
complètement inadmissible et je pense
même que c'est volontaire ils font
passer un message là c'est ces joueurs
là font passer un message parce que il
pourrait très bien le porter il le porte
tous ces centaines de joueurs qui l'ont
porté pendant le pendant les matchs de
de cette de cette journée là je ne Liga
toi tu cites le cas spécifique
les familles sont menacées
c'est le cas de Mostafa Mohamed mais
c'est un cas totalement isolé le reste
tu le sais tu le sais parce que de toute
façon les gens qui vont
comment dire préparer cette action qui
vont dans les clubs il y a 10 clubs qui
ont été visités avec des personnes qui
vont parler qui qui disent ce qui va se
passer et ce pourquoi on va le faire la
très grande majorité ce sont des
Français sont pas des étrangers gay et
Mohamed Mosta sont des cas totalement
isolés donc ton excuse de ils sont en
danger chez eux encore une fois dans ces
cas-là ils viennent pas dans le
changement
tout le reste tous les autres qui
comptent les personnes vont préparer
cette journée dans les clubs qui font la
Réunion et qu'ils disent il va se passer
ça et ça et quand ils essaient des
insultent des siffler j'étais venu ici
raconter ce que j'ai dit dans mon livre
CAO Football Club ou parce que la
nouvelle génération ça va être terrible
c'est pire les jeunes dans les centres
de formation c'est pire ils ne veulent
même pas en entendre parler quand on
vient leur parler et quand on veut les
sensibiliser à ce genre de de
la propulsion de pollen de d'éventuels
polémique ils ne veulent même pas en
entendre parler une des personnes qui
qui tient ce genre de réunion et qui va
me raconter deux fois à trois une
première fois notamment à terminer et à
Bastia c'était encore pire il a terminé
dans sa bagnole chasser à coup de pompe
voilà voilà on en est et la jeune
génération ça va être encore pire mais
c'est un vrai souci mais peut-être
qu'au-delà de cette journée il faudrait
aller en profondeur travailler dans les
clubs mais c'est ce qui est fait
travailler dans les clubs c'est ce que
je suis en train de te raconter ils le
font et ça marche pas forcément ça
marche pas mais le pire je vais vous
dire mais le pire c'est d'entendre Eric
roi entraîneur de Brest c'est d'entendre
Bruno Génésio l'entraîneur de Rennes
c'est de ne pas entendre un seul
président s'exprimer sauf non disons
décidé de sanctionner le Nantais d'une
journée de salaire parce qu'il a pas
voulu travailler et des entraîneurs qui
sont là qui disent ouais ils ont pas
choisi le bon jour pour pour cette
journée contre l'homophobie et puis
l'autre ouais on devrait pas nous
demander ça tiens en gros en gros c'est
pour pas être emmerdé pour parler joueur
donc en fait eux ce que ces joueurs l'a
dit c'est qu'ils veulent qu'on respecte
leur intolérance tout leur message c'est
ça ils veulent qu'on respecte leur
intolérance il y a 15 jours je crois que
je suis venu je sais pas si je suis venu
pour cette occasion mais vous avez fait
le débat autour du Ramadan ils veulent
qu'on respecte ça chez eux mais en
revanche eux ne veulent pas du tout
respecter autre chose ils veulent
ce qui les intéresse à eux parce qu'on
est dans une société aujourd'hui qui est
complètement fracturée totalement
communautaire il n'y a plus d'intérêt
collectifs ou de causes communes ou de
valeur républicaines ou de loi c'est
chacun ses convictions personnelles et
encore plus quand elles sont religieuses
qui doivent dominer c'est ça qui domine
plus que tout ce qui est pas étonnant
d'ailleurs parce que quand on voit des
sondages sur une population 15 25 ans 30
ans
75% de des jeunes disent que leur
convictions religieuses sont plus
importantes que les lois de la
République c'est une constante sur
toutes les enquêtes aujourd'hui
il faut pas que ça tourne au débat
anti-musulmans voilà j'ai peur de ça
bien sûr
le Guingampais le Guingampais qui a
refusé il est évangélique oui c'est
c'est une forme d'extrémisme soyez pas
vous êtes toujours
mais je suis français
il se trouve qu'il y a une major la
Major de ceux qui sont s’exprimer
effectivement son musulmans il y a une
nouvelle tendance effectivement dans les
clubs qu'on ne connaissait pas avec des
des nouveaux des évangéliques parce que
ça existe également c'était pas très
fréquent en France on envoyait très peu
mais il y en a d'ailleurs le Guingampais
en étant mais aussi merci je voudrais
dire bonjour Daniel on est on est très
content que tu sois passé de dire tout
ça parce que c'est important pour nous
que tu viens nous faire un peu ce coup
de gueule je rappelle ton livre chaos
Football Club qui est disponible partout
merci d'ailleurs quand tu veux vraiment
et c'est vrai que c'était voilà moi
j'avais pas trop suivi l'histoire parce
que voilà j'étais sur un pays 2000 au
paddle et puis j'étais sur un
anniversaire de mon fils là j'ai vu
qu'on avait beaucoup parlé le weekend
chargé donc j'ai vu qu'il y avait plein
de gens qui s'agitaient sur Twitter
autour de moi les gars j'ai rien vu j'en
ai rien à Carry voilà donc oui 45%
doivent-ils extensionner non 54%. c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est
sérieux mais pas mais pas trop